[Music]
i'm eric gray from vmware and in this
video you'll see how to quickly set up a
vmware nsx segment with dhcp services
to get started log into the vmware
engine portal and access the cloud owner
credentials which provides admin access
to vcenter the summary screen also lets
you view the nsx password and you can
easily reference the integrated dns
server addresses here too
links to the vsphere client and other
admin interfaces are under the vsphere
management network tab
experienced vsphere admins will have no
difficulty transferring their skills to
the familiar vmware engine environment
under the networking tab you can see
there are several networks that support
the private cloud infrastructure but
none of these are for workload vms
return to the portal and follow the same
procedure one more time to obtain nsx
manager credentials and launch the web
interface
navigate to the networking tab and
select dhcp under ip management
add a dhcp profile and provide a name
you can leave the server ip address
field blank
select the existing edge cluster and
click save
once the dhcp profile is created
navigate to tier 1 gateways edit the
configuration for the gateway named tier
1.
enable dhcp by clicking set dhcp
configuration change the type to dhcp
server and select the dhcp profile that
you created in the previous step
save the configuration changes and close
the editing dialog
to create a workload network navigate to
segments and click add segment
provide a name for the network and
select the tier 1 gateway and the tz
overlay transport zone
in the subnets configuration enter the
ip address you plan to allocate for the
gateway interface as well as an
appropriate cider length for the network
to provide dhcp services to this segment
click set dhcp config
click the switch to enable the config
and enter the desired range of dynamic
addresses
specify the dns servers that your
workloads require you can use public
servers centralized enterprise servers
or the pair of dns servers that are part
of the private cloud infrastructure
save the configuration changes to finish
creating the network segment
click network topology to see a diagram
of the environment
finally jump back to the vsphere client
to see the newly created segment in the
list of networks
now you're ready to deploy a virtual
machine on your google cloud vmware
engine private cloud
check out the next video in this series
to learn how
to learn more about google cloud vmware
engine visit our site at
cloud.google.com
vmware dash engine
[Music]
you